[Music]
my background
is quite mixed so i was born and raised
in adisaba ethiopia where
i was really interested in mathematics
so i
that was what i was exploring and i
ended up
at harvard college where i majored in
mathematics but
at the same time i was also really
interested in
questions related to inequality and
discrimination
in the city of cambridge where i was
living and studying as a college student
it's interesting to look back now but
sort of the writing was on the wall
because i was thinking about how
algorithms that are being used to assign
students to public schools
were creating and exacerbating
inequality that exists
and how those same algorithms could
actually be used
to mitigate some of those inequalities i
realized that actually
i could explore both my interest in
mathematics and my interest in questions
around inequality and discrimination
at the same time as a computer scientist
so that's how sort of i lend it from
my background in math to what i do now
my work
is really focused on questions around
inequality and discrimination what i
usually do is i
you know i have a couple domains that
i'm really interested in so
economic welfare housing education
are domains where i'm i've been pretty
deeply embedded
i think about ways in which
discrimination plays out in these
domains
ways in which we're not maybe doing a
very good job measuring the inequality
or the sort of disadvantage that people
are facing and then
after doing that i also think about what
can be done about this right what can be
done to measure it so
one example that i'll give you is um
we've been thinking a lot about
different income shocks that people
experience right so these income shocks
could be
something as large as let's say uh you
know you you get sick and now you have
this major
medical expense or it could be something
small like you know your paycheck was
delayed by a week or maybe you got a
parking ticket right
and so these different types of shocks
have differential impact on people so
some people
may not necessarily even notice if their
paycheck was delayed by a week right but
other people
that could be the reason why they end up
getting evicted and so
what we've been doing is both modeling
that and thinking about how
we can allocate different types of
resources and subsidies
and different poverty alleviation
programs to address
not just sort of these straightforward
ways of measuring
uh poverty or discrimination or
disadvantage but also these
more subtle ways that uh that we know to
be important
we've also been working with some data
sets uh for instance we're seeing that a
lot of male individuals
uh when they experience um something
with the criminal justice system let's
say they are stopped by the police they
uh they're robbed you know there's
something that they've experienced with
the criminal justice system or crime in
general
it seems like that that really
deeply impacts experiences they have
with poverty whereas for
female individuals from this data set
when they have experiences with
financial shocks like
they lose benefits they have some major
expense things like that
that seems to have a much deeper impact
on female
female respondents from the survey that
we've been working with so we've been
doing both sort of the
modeling and theoretical set of
questions to extract qualitative
insights about how we should be
designing
our poverty alleviation programs but
then also the computational work to
learn from the ground up what are people
experiencing
i think that the world would be a much
better place if
anyone cared more about not just social
issues but really specifically
issues that are being faced by
communities on the margins of society i
really think so and certainly this is
true of computer scientists as well
right now in computer science i think
that we've made some progress so i don't
want to
completely be negative about this but
but there are some serious issues around
one just representation of communities
in the field if people are not there to
see what their problems are
and ways in which they're being left
behind we're not really going to make
progress i think a lot of times
we assume that we can just go and learn
about other communities and we can
kind of proxy represent them and that's
just at best a stop gap
once you have people within that
community you need to actually make sure
that they're empowered that they're
getting the resources that they need
that they feel heard
right and that their contributions are
valued in the same way as anyone else
who's around and that issue of sort of
equity and inclusion
this is where we usually lose the battle
right people get people through the door
and then they say okay well what more do
you want you know we have
people of this group here isn't that
enough no it's absolutely not enough in
fact
if you're doing it wrong it's actually
worse because now you've put in people
in an environment where they're not
going to thrive where they're not going
to succeed
we've been kind of stuck in this
representation uh
goal right just let's get people through
the door just enough of them that we
don't feel bad about it and that's
and that's enough and that's not enough
right we really need to make sure that
we're continuing to make progress
i did my dissertation defense back in
november 2019
and this was 2019 and i was the first
black woman
at cornell computer science to defend
her thesis i was the first black woman
in its entire history and you know it
was it was on it obviously an honor it
was something that was really exciting
to me
but it was also a weight that i felt
right because i was thinking about
all the other black women who would have
loved to have done their degree at
cornell cs and they weren't able to do
that
and what was really heartwarming for me
but also kind of sad was that
at my defense um a bunch of
undergraduate students showed up a bunch
of black undergraduate students showed
up
to to watch my defense i've never seen
that before and i
and i was just so i don't even know how
they knew about it but they showed up
they showed up in mass and it was this
really heartwarming thing for me to have
them
and you know when you do your defense
there's a bit that
you know where the person who's
defending goes out and then the
committee stays in and they discuss
you know you know do you pass or do you
not pass whatever
so i stepped out for the committee to
discuss on their own and the undergrads
were waiting for me
and and it was just really heartwarming
because not only were they waiting they
were crying
because it was just so meaningful to
them to see me and it was just so
meaningful to me
it really stuck with me because i would
have loved to see that when i was an
undergrad i would have loved
to see a defense by another black woman
right and so i think that we need to
think about
not just you know what can we get out of
like representation right like
can we get the right people here so they
can give us the right answers and they
can make us look good right
i feel like a lot of times that's like
the tone that i get but just like
what are we showing to our students that
we're supposed to be serving what are we
showing
to them about what we value in our
community and i think that's something
that
is incredibly important that's not
talked about enough
so black and ai was started
as a it was really started as
actually as an email list and then a
facebook group really what was happening
was
there were several of us who knew each
other or knew of one another
and each of us were you know
unsurprisingly the only black person at
our institution right i was you know
sort of the only black person at
cornell you know timmy gabriel my
co-founder was sort of one of few people
at stanford and so on right so each of
us were sort of feeling isolated
and we wanted to come together in a way
that was
not just an annual conference right we
wanted to just sort of stay in touch
with one another exchange ideas and
kind of support one another but it very
quickly grew you know it went from
30 people to 300 people in like a span
of one month and
you know it's been three years or
something and now we're at close to 4
000 people
what's happened is that people have used
this critical mass that we have
to identify patterns of exclusion that
we're experiencing so for instance
in black and ai i run the academic
program and
what we've identified there is that
there are a lot of people who want to
pursue graduate school
and they can't because they can't afford
to take the gre you know they take the
gre
they can't retake it they take the gre
they don't have money to send scores to
different institutions
um you know there's just all sorts of
different issues it's not just the gre
and so
what we've been able to do is to
systematically
document and identify these barriers
that individuals are facing and to
identify ways that we can counter that
so
one thing that's happened that i'm
really excited about is
we ran this academic program for people
applying to graduate programs
and each year there's about 200 people
who apply to graduate programs we
systematically documented barriers that
they're facing
and we took that and we gave it to
universities and we said listen
you you have an institution that has
no black people or maybe a handful of
black people maybe
right you're not even getting
applications that you should be getting
because there are all these barriers
that you're not thinking about
we were able to kind of share these
insights with institutions
and really change how some institutions
do things so at berkeley where i am
we removed the gre we made adjustments
to
how we evaluate candidates we made sure
that we actually evaluated every
candidate
who is applying to graduate programs by
actually reading their applications
and reading it in a way i'm not going to
compare you to someone else who had
access to more things i'm going to look
at what you have access to and what you
did with those opportunities
and from that make a decision about you
know whether i think you're going to
take full advantage of being at berkeley
versus not and
it made a huge difference our admitted
class is over 15 percent uh
a block among those working in ai
actually over 15 15
block and and these are some some of the
most incredible people you've ever met
and doing
some of the most innovative work that
i've that i've ever seen
but work that could be totally missed if
it's being evaluated by
a group of homogeneous people you know
homogeneous community that
doesn't necessarily understand the
diversity of problems that are out there
and sort of the
the diversity of ways in which you can
show your strength
as a researcher